first no looks trick shot not too  complicated  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  we'll need two pongfinity rackets for  this one  [Music]  now look back and chop  [Music]  level 40.  [Music]  time for a backhand atm  [Music]  remember to check out our very own table  tennis products from pongfinity.store  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  i can't see how this is going to work  out  [Music]  yes  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  level 75.  [Music]  oh  [Music]  ball to the cup  [Music]  oh i got it  oh first right  [Music]  let's get high for this one  [Music]  go and get yourself some quality table  tennis products or a cool present from  our very own web store confinity gold  store until next time  [Music]